[Music]
let's talk to kathy in
boston
hey kathy listen
before we get going here okay i'm an
astros fan and if you're from boston
they're about to play your red sox by
the time this episode comes out we'll
know the outcome of this series but i'm
just letting you know just letting you
know okay i'm starting this conversation
a little bit on edge but that's cool so
what's up
well um thank you for taking my call you
got it and
um i have a situation at home um my
husband and i are both 52
and my son is 25
he lives at home he's been unemployed
for a year he doesn't collect
unemployment and every time we try to
get him out of the house he refuses to
leave
and he doesn't want to talk about
his past situation
with his last job which i do know what
had happened
but he's using that as an excuse to why
he can't get a job that he needs to work
things through why do you
what do you mean when he won't leave
your house what does that mean
well we've tried to kick him out a
couple times because he really um ticked
off me and my husband how do you try to
kick him out
like he's 25 year old man you tell him
you put all the stuff in the yard or you
call the police
well he doesn't leave the house so it's
hard to
get into his room
and throw everything out kathy this is
your house
well
i i know he's your son i know you love
him
but it sounds like you're encouraging
him to leave or you might get loud but i
feel like i'm enabling him yeah
absolutely one thousand percent why
doesn't any why doesn't he work what
happened at the last job
um
it's a long situation but basically
in one sentence what happened
he misread a girl's
actions and he got fired for sexual
harassment but he did not you know he
nothing physical happened okay he got
fired for sexual harassment and wha what
does he do what's his trade what does he
do for a living what does he want to do
usually he works in warehouses but his
dream is to be a writer a director
and he stays at home and he
writes i mean he's not just playing
video games i mean he doesn't really
play video games but he's always in his
room whenever i go in there he's either
writing
reading
you know
not just
playing video games so here's the thing
he wants you know why he stays at home
because it's comfortable because he can
you know he doesn't have a job because
he can
why he
reads books as a 25 year old and isn't
contributing to your home or to his
community or even furthering his career
because he can
and my guess is
there's no
not my guess is there's no way this is
new
how long have you guys been propping him
up for probably since he was really
little huh
um
yeah but he's always been pretty
independent on us
on his own my daughter was the one who
needed all the attention but i mean he's
always
you know he's always been quiet i mean
it's just this past year has been
it's just been he won't work he won't
get a job my husband and i have tried to
get him a job
between where i
between my two jobs
he doesn't need one he doesn't need a
job
why would he work because it would be
insane for him to work
he has the greatest situation any 25
year old not with a romantic partner
could dream of
free food free rent he just gets to read
books all day and write the great
american novel or write a screenplay
he doesn't have to do anything
true
like like finding him a job is is like a
fruitless exercise he's already he
doesn't need one he's got everything
taken care of
and so what do you suggest oh go ahead
yeah i mean i don't you know what to do
i don't need to suggest anything to you
you have one of two options
you can continue just to support him and
then maybe one day
um
his great american screenplay will come
through
probably
less than
one one thousandth of a percent chance
that happens because screenwriters are
on set screenwriters are getting coffee
for people i know i've known
screenwriters
people in the industry are in the
industry they are hustling 365 24 7 and
then they write at night
they are around
films being made they are around other
writers they have writer's groups
they're sending their stuff they're
always in the middle of things
you want to you want to find people who
are in the film industry i work with
some of them they are all over the place
sarah right here makes movies in the
evening and edits them and cuts the i
mean it's a people who are in that and
make it are doing it 24 7 365 they're
not in their mom's house
in
the reading books
so
he's not gonna be successful doing this
but maybe maybe he'll send the email
that the great agent opens and such and
such or you can give him the greatest
gift a parent could give him
which is responsibility
participation and consequences
accountability that's love
right that's what we want to give them
you don't want to make them homeless you
don't want to give it to him you want to
want to give it to him
no i do want to give it to him i'm just
afraid of making him homeless he might
be homeless but that won't be you making
him that would be a 25 year old man
choosing it
do you see the difference
i do
it's it it is not your responsibility if
you're a 25 year old man of a son
chooses to be homeless at this point
does he have mental health issues
does he have physical health issues
no physical health issues but um
you know mental illness does run in the
family i mean i have my
um bipolar and um anxiety issues my
daughter has care issues i mean
do i think he's dealing with depression
yeah absolutely yeah millions of people
are dealing with depression it's been an
ugly ugly couple of years no question
about it
but my guess is
at some point a 24 year old is sitting
there staring at a warehouse and doesn't
know what to do next and then he just
cashes out here's what i'm gonna do i
want you to stay on the line i'm gonna
send you something for free for him
i'm gonna send you my friend ken coleman
has a career assessment he's got a new
book coming out i'm gonna send both of
them to you for free
okay oh thank you
but here's the thing
you're going to give that to him and
then you're going to give him an i'm not
going to tell you what to do because
here's what's going to happen i'm going
to tell you you need to kick him out
which you do
and then you're going to and then he's
going to be homeless and something's
going to happen you're going to blame me
that's what enablers do no no no okay so
i wouldn't blame you
if it's my kid he's out of my house in
30 days
he's out of my house in 60 days i might
even pay his first month's rent of his
new one-bedroom apartment
but he's got 60 days
30 days and then he's gone
and here's a couple of tools to help you
find out what you want to do because you
don't do warehouse forever maybe you do
maybe you want to work up the supply
chain
you're going to have to write your
screenplay at night because you got to
eat brother because i'm not feeding you
anymore
i'm not paying your bills anymore
and kathy you know this you know this
right i do i really do and your husband
he knows this
absolutely
so who's who's protecting your son one
of you two is is at the last minute goes
no no no let's let him stay another
night who is it is it you me
me
man
love your son enough to hold him
responsible for his actions he's a 25
year old man now's the time
okay
so i guess uh
i'll be throwing his stuff out the
window
hey i've seen it where it gets ugly he
says i'm not leaving and then he's going
to call your bluff
and then you got to decide yeah that's
what he has been doing am i going to
call the police
are we going to take all of his stuff
and have it moved out of my of your home
and actually it's your stuff unless he
purchased it with his own money so if
it's beds and dressers and things that
y'all bought at y'alls
but at some point he's gonna call your
bluff and you're gonna have to decide
ahead of time so take your your husband
out and you say i'm sorry that i've been
kicking this candy on the road for five
ten
fifteen
twenty years it's time for a son to grow
up
and i know it's hard and i know there's
a pandemic and blah blah blah he's gotta
start grinding
he's got to start figuring out life as
our friend my friend henry cloud says
what he's in desperate need is some
problems
he needs some actual problems like
hunger and
shelter
to get his butt and gear he's got to go
to work
and if you are 25 at home
working on your screenplay and you don't
have a job go get a job
figure it out man that's
frustrating frustrating frustrating
frustrating
and i know it's hard kathy now's the
time you got to make your move make your
move